Shawn is with us in Shreveport hey Shawn
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey
mister Angie thank you so much for
taking my call
sure what's up hey so I'm about to get
married in May congratulations you're in
thank you so much I appreciate that I'm
just wondering what steps to me and my
fiance need to take because I've been
listening to your YouTube channel for
about over a year now and I've kind of
been wanting to go headfirst into it all
in but she's kind of lackluster on on
getting in with me mm-hmm
okay well I are you guys doing any pre
marriage counseling
no you should you should it'sit's very
valuable and there's a lot of
statistical evidence that indicates that
you then a good pre marriage counselor
will increase the likelihood of the
success of your marriage number one
number two all the data on marriage that
we've been able to put together over the
years of doing what we do here tells us
that if you can be in agreement on four
things prior to marriage that you
increase your chance of success on the
marriage almost completely I mean it's
amazing the difference number one thing
that people argue about in marriage
number one cause of divorce is money
fights and money problems so being in
disagreement about money is a problem
that's a big deal you got to solve that
number two being in agreement about kids
whether we're gonna have them how we're
going to treat them and so on
I want 19 kids I don't want kids is a
problem
I want to let our kids run wild and buck
Nick it down the street and no I want to
make our kids behave that's a problem
the third thing is to be in agreement
about your extended family the in-laws
and how you're going to deal with them
because there are problems in your
families and you need to have an
agreement on how we're going to treat
each other how we're going to handle
them and so forth and the last one is
being agreement about religion if you're
in agreement on those four areas
you're going to have a very successful
marriage on average that's what the data
tells us okay any one of those and
you've got a problem any three of those
and you're not gonna make it
statistically right okay
so all of that to say the number one one
is being an agreement about money so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna give you
Financial Peace University membership as
my wedding gift awesome thank you so
much it's a one-year membership there
are nine lessons that you go to at your
local church there and you sit through
those nine lessons together and that'll
be part of your pre marriage counseling
even if you both agree that Dave Ramsey
is a fool and you don't want to do any
of it at least be in agreement okay but
you know so I think that'll help you
start with a really really solid
foundation a lot of people actually use
Financial Peace University as part of
their pre marriage counseling it's not a
substitute for pre marriage counseling
but it's part of it because when you can
get on a again on the same page about
money you're really agreeing about your
life Jesus said your treasure is where
your heart is so you spend your money on
and you handle your money on what's
important to you you prioritize it shows
up what you believe about life shows up
in your checkbook and so to be in
agreement on your values to be an
agreement on what you value to have a
oneness a unity about that is a huge
head start in a new marriage so I'll
give that to you you hold on have Kelly
pick up I don't want to give it to you
and you go by yourself if you go by
yourself you'll probably in the
engagement I prefer that you go together
because I want you to grow together I
want this to be a a bonding time a thing
that creates unity a thing that creates
communication a thing that creates
agreement between the two of you because
that'll be a huge gift to your new
marriage if you'll do that so hold on
I'll have Kelly pick up and we'll get
you signed up for all the stuff in
Financial Peace University thanks Sean
and congratulations